[music]
Hi everyone, thank you for joining our
very exciting session with the three new
companies that are looking to do very
different things but very exciting
things. Uh so I would like to uh first
of all I'm Slana Grant. I am a strategic
partnerships manager with Google deep
mind. working very closely with the
robotics companies and working very
closely with multiple partners who are
helping us to bring AI in robotics to
the real world developing foundational
models and we have recently started
working with several exciting startups
uh as part of the Google accelerator
program and today we have uh three of
them and they're going to tell us all a
little bit about the technologies
they're developing about the use cases
that that they're building and also some
of the interesting challenges that uh
their particular use cases are
presenting. Um so I have today um from
from your um from your right from my
left uh doc Dr. Zakis Hussein who is the
founder and CEO of Touch Lab. Uh we have
Patricia Apostl who's the CTO of Bubble
Robotics and we have Jan Eric Sullen who
is the CEO of co-founder of stair. So
three companies very different. Um I am
going to probably let you talk a little
bit about uh your individual companies.
You each have very different
experiences. You know some of you are on
your ends startup third fourth. I mean
there have been a few some of the some
some of the um uh exciting exits have
already taken place. So that's that's
great. I hope you you can mention some
of that. Um and uh Patricia, some of you
are also doing some of the incredibly
hard things that are very remote and um
you know, completely um far from the I
guess from the civilization looking to
to explore and um monitor the oceans. Um
you know, touch lab is developing iskin
tactile sensors. That's kind of the new
um I guess uh the new border of the
robotics. So coming on top of all of the
um computer vision and all of the
manipulation and uh now kind of a new um
a new push for for the robotics
companies to add intelligence to to the
robots and uh Yaneric you are moving
from the world of maps and various
various roles that looked after the maps
and open source community now moving
into a kind of more indoors and more
enclosed factory type of environment of
of and the world of digital twins. So a
little bit of a different setup. So all
of you are facing your your interesting
um new challenges and um I'm going to
give you a minute each um tell a little
bit about your companies. Um yeah,
Zachi, we are going to start with you
please.
>> Sure. Thank you very much. Um yeah, so
I'm Dr. Zaki Hussein. I'm the CEO and
founder of Touch Lab. Uh we're actually
a company based in Scotland uh in
Edinburgh and um we make basically skin
for robots, tactile sensing skin that is
thinner than human skin and that means
we can integrate it pretty much
everywhere on a robot. Um one of our
integrations that we're scaling up now
is robot fingertips which we would like
to be on as many robots as possible very
soon. Um, but we also work on the the AI
layer, um, which is really to understand
what touch represents, what it means,
what are these tactile features, how do
you do reasoning, how do you plug them
into a VA, for example. Um, so I think
that sort of summarizes it. My
background is really doing a PhD in this
field of electronic skin. I've been here
for 12 years. 10 years ago, people said,
"This is crazy. This is never going to
happen. There's no point." And now
people are getting excited. So that's
great.
>> Thank you, Patricia. Over to you. Yes.
So, hi all. I'm Patty. I'm CTO of Bubble
Robotics. I am a first-time founder, no
exits, and aerospace engineer now
tackling the ocean space. So, yeah, at
Bubble, we fundamentally believe that
the ocean holds the key to the biggest
challenges of our century from, you
know, renewable energy to things like uh
national security. And it's just that
scaling anything in the ocean today,
given that the surfaces are way larger
than they were before, is extremely
expensive. and extremely extremely
unsafe. It's a really harsh place out
there, maybe even harsher than space.
And I never thought I would actually say
that. So, at Bubble, we're trying to
build robots that can live in the sea.
So, our vision is building sort of cube
sets of the ocean that can today see and
hear underwater and down the line also
act in order to be able to actually
perform those extremely safety critical
tasks. And yeah, that's where we are
today.
>> Great. Thank you, Patty. Yan, Eric, over
to you.
>> All right. Uh hello everyone. I'm
Yoneric uh CEO and co-founder of Stair.
Uh yes, I am on my nth startup. Um I've
been in computer vision my whole life
and fortunate enough to build some uh
some fun companies that exited to Apple
and and Meta in the past. And uh so I
come into robotics with a mapping
background and um we build self-updating
3D maps for mobile robots and we help
warehouses with observability figuring
out where everything is flows and and
things like that how things are moving
around in their space and uh also
coordination of both human and robotic
workers.
>> Great. Thank you very much. So three
different companies. Uh I will open the
floor at the end for more questions. So
um if you have one burning um stay with
us and we'll give you an opportunity to
ask it. But let me let me start with a
couple of questions that that I've been
keen to explore. And um Zachi if I can
start with you uh I mean we you know uh
we call them VA so vision you know
language automation and uh action models
and um you know you are dealing with now
the haptic touch and and a slightly
different beast of of data um you know
for robots that have relied on imitation
learning and on motion learning and
teleop and so on. um how do you see this
type of data incorporated into the new
robotic models and what are the types of
challenges that you are dealing with?
>> That's um that's a great question. So
in a way um yeah this tactile
information basically that we're that
we're obtaining is it's sort of um more
physical than what we're used to. So
obviously it's required for robots to
basically in my opinion the simplest way
I could summarize it is for them not to
be clumsy and to be able to dextrously
handle real world items. Um so
traditionally I mean every time you go
and grasp an object um once you've grasp
it you get a visual occlusion. You don't
actually see exactly what's happening
with the contact physics. Um you need to
you need to feel it. Um and of course um
yeah so this is kind of justifying why
we're using this. Now the there's sort
of I would say almost three different
layers to how you can interpret actile
information. Um the first one is trying
to make sure that you can get something
like a VTLA uh vision tactile uh
language action model
>> where you incorporate tactile into it.
So um the first VA I think was made by
by Google deep mind in 2023 the RT2 and
now VALA's are very common um in the
industry because you need to incorporate
all of this data and do reasoning on it.
So the next question is how do you bring
that tactile data in? How do you
represent it? So the first layer is
building the hardware to to gather your
ground truth data. um really there
hasn't really been great tactile
hardware out there period to gather uh
really accurate ground truth data. So
this is why we you know I set out at
building skins skins that are extremely
robust extremely accurate can are
durable to millions of cycles. This this
had been done maybe a little bit in
other spaces but not not in a skin
format. Uh again there are other sensors
out there. Um, so you get the raw data
from the sensor and you can look at it
as a sort of a matrix array of data. You
can even sort of flatten it out and
almost look at it as visual data
frankly. So there are a few different
ways you could plug it into a VA. If you
represented as vision type data where
you just have a matrix array of, for
example, vectors or RGB data, you can
actually process and learn off it in a
similar way as you would uh from vision
based data. This is why the first
tactile sensors that came out are vision
based. they were basically cameras
because you can use all the same tools
that you normally use. But when you have
a more accurate type of tactile sensor,
you might need to uh custom train AI
models. So this is what we are currently
doing. There's a couple of different
layers as I said. First is the raw data
layer. Then it's something called um
tactile feature extraction or
understanding. I'm going to call this
tactile intelligence. And then the top
layer is the VA layer. What do you do?
What do you reason? What does this
information actually tell you? One
feature that we're working on very hard
on that tactile feature extraction
middle layer is the understanding of
slippage. When does an object slip? Can
we identify all the different objects
that are going to slip? Um, and can we
react to those? Because in the human
body, you're not reacting from your
brain. You're actually your spinal cord
processes part of that data and reacts
faster than you consciously even
realize.
Right? So we need to program in
reactions at a layer that is embodied
and processed locally in the body of the
robot, not in the brain to be fast
enough. VAS are too slow. They are
they're too slow at the moment to
process that level of data and react.
Um, so I was very happy that this year
we did a unique demo at the biggest
robot conference in the world. We are
able to grasp melting ice and prevent
the ice from slipping while it's
melting,
right? So this is pretty hard, but we
can do that with a robot now.
>> Yeah. Okay. And in this new world of
VTLAS, welcome to a new acronym. um in
um I mean there's not a lot of haptic
data still available and you know I know
data is one of the big uh challenges I
guess for training the uh the robotic
models when do you think we're going to
have enough to train the models and do
you already see sort of the
breakthroughs coming or are there more
challenges for you to address
>> that's a that's a great question so I
think the whole industry is now talking
about a a data bottleneck Um, when it
comes to learning, having enough data to
train your model, I think there's a few,
um, again coming from the tactile
perspective, there's a few different
things. I don't think anybody knows what
kind of data and how much data they
need. We're on a we're leading the
tactile efforts of Arya, which is the
advanced research and invention agency's
efforts in the UK. And the the question
that we're basically trying to answer
the question, what type of data, how
much data do you actually need? Um I've
been in the business for a while now. Um
and a lot of the time clients would tell
us we need this very high spec of this
or that and then they'd tell us
something else when we delivered that
spec and then again we'd end up in this
never- ending code development cycle. So
we started building our own robot
systems, our own applications. Uh we've
got our own dextrous rig with a shadow
robot hand in Edinburgh and our
fingertips and our senses all over it.
Um so yes, one thing is gathering the
right type of data. Uh you may have
heard Burnt talk about data gloves out
there. So he wants to give um people uh
in like individuals data gloves which
you can train your own robot to do stuff
using your own data in your own
application. I think that's a really
interesting idea.
I actually think that a lot of the time
we don't need um necessarily
the right data. We need good ground
truth data, but we might not need the
resolution of data that humans have.
We have thousands of sensors per cime
squared in our fingertips.
Um, and I think we don't need that to do
95% of the tasks out there. Maybe we
just need very good few sensors in the
right areas of the body or the hand or
the finger. And we need to process that
data fast enough and we need to
understand what it represents well
enough. Um and again yeah so I think I
think it's quite interesting there's a
data bottleneck but I actually don't
think the industry necessarily
understands it's not just data quantity
and volume you need to train a model and
then there's another side of it which
maybe we'll come to later is online
learning. If you look at humans we
actually learn um we don't train our
model initially and then go test it out.
We continuously learn by interacting
with the environment. A baby learns by
putting stuff in its mouth and feeling
it and it starts to understand the 3D
world around it. So I think that online
learning when it when it happens is
going to be a key as well to unlocking
some of this.
>> Okay. Amazing. Thank you. And with a lot
of emphasis now on dextrous and on
manipulation, I think that's that's
quite an important development and we
hope that we can see exciting things
from you. Um moving on to Patricia. Um
uh you you mentioned that that you're
looking really to operate in one of the
most hostile uh environments. Um it you
know it it it's a it's an environment
that that is going to um have a robot
basically disconnected from any networks
and working with the models that have to
live I suppose on that on that robot. I
mean, how do you see that whole paradigm
of having access to to the model
somewhere in the cloud as well as the
model on the edge? Where where do you
see the that sort of optimal combination
for for you?
>> Yeah. So um I'm going to give a bit of a
more let's say boring or or customer
centric uh answer to this and that is
there is no optimal level um at at
bubble because we actually operate on
hugely critical infrastructure
where seeing what's going on in the loop
before you can go around with super
fancy edge stuff is extremely important.
Um but before that you're probably
wondering like what does this robot that
lives in the sea look like? So, it's
actually again a little bit maybe more
standard. It's a two-part system. So, we
actually have a sort of pretty small,
we're strongly working on
miniaturaturization mother ship at the
surface that then can deploy various
types of sensors subsea, but
specifically another underwater robot to
gather closer up uh data to certain
assets or for instance the seabed. And
these two for the moment remain tethered
and will remain tethered for a long
period of time especially as we derisk a
lot of the algorithms on edge moving
towards untethered uh systems. This
means that fundamentally we actually can
run absolutely everything on board the
mother ship and so the mother ship is
actually connected to shore pretty much
247. we have a let's say triple
redundant communication system and once
we lose communication to the mother ship
we stop all operations right so if we
lose it on the data side we consider the
backup system if the backup system
doesn't work um we essentially stop we
perform a sort of let's say goaround
type of maneuver where we try to regain
connectivity we don't we turn on our
light and someone comes get us it's as
simple as that it's it's not so so AI
oriented where we do use or I guess
somewhat because where we do actually
use a lot of of our edge algorithms is
more about the certain checks. So I
spoke about losing connectivity to the
mother ship or the so-called bubble
dock. Uh but we can also lose
connectivity to the bubble bot the
underwater system. And in that case
super simple we we essentially have to
reperform our docking maneuver which is
not so simple to actually be able to
tell you know is it docked or not. So
there we can actually use a lot of our
perception algorithm board, our actuator
checks and let's say our sort of status
checks to make sure that happens and
then we abort the mission and simply
just move on. So that is sort of how the
the critical the critical and safety
aspects are handled. Um yeah otherwise
no one is going to let you operate near
your asset. There is no way.
>> Right. So you have a plan B and a plan C
and a plan D.
>> Yeah.
>> And then you basically come up for air.
That's great.
>> Plan D is you stop. You hold. Yeah.
Okay. And I have to ask you a data
question as well. I mean, you know, um,
again, we're talking about the the need
for data to train the models. How do you
work around the challenge that very
little of that data exists, uh, for, you
know, for the oceans and for the type of
data you really need to train?
>> Yeah, absolutely. So, what we're
fundamentally building is the full
solution to that challenge. So when I
said that we're building cubats for the
ocean or robots that live at sea, I
really do mean robots that live at sea.
So we're targeting up to 12 months of
operation of continuous data acquisition
247 both at the surface and subc in
order to directly actually address that
um data data bottleneck, right? Which is
extremely hard to get because a lot of
the terrestrial models today or you know
VA's foundational models are trained on
terrestrial physics, right? So friction
coefficients and sort of heat behaviors
right well subc things are a lot slower
which is kind of nice but are completely
different right or can only be nicely
solved with something like the Navier
Stokes equations. So by building
something resident we can actually
facilitate that from the ground up and
then also facilitate more challenging
tasks as we shift towards those
manipulation settings down the line. Um
now yes of course we need simulation
especially because we're looking at
deploying very much in a marriage
between the surface system and the
underwater system. So the interaction
between those two really matters in
terms of the efficiency of how we
actually inspect these critical um
offshore assets but limit uh limitation
but simulation is really limited. So you
can use something like Majoko from from
Deep Mind on sort of like basic physics
like for instance our whole like docking
uh docking cone counter cone uh type of
hardware that works really nicely but if
you're looking at things like perception
underwater you have to create these
really simil simulic realistic
environments um and yeah we are working
on that in house but you're you're still
limited nothing is going to be compared
I mean the the the sea is so stochastic
it's the most stocastic environment you
can be in it's more stocastic than you
know being in space orbit. So yeah,
that's that's why we're building this
foundation from the ground up.
>> Okay. Okay. Exciting. So from one
stochastic environment to um yik to your
your area of the environments where you
have a lot of things changing all the
time. Uh the virtual environments, how
are you dealing with this sort of
challenge with a lot of data that
presumably goes um stale and very
obsolete very quickly?
Uh yeah, I I mean my heart warmed a
little bit when you said Navier Stokes.
It's it's pretty good for a for an
oldtime mathematician. Um yeah, so in in
the warehouse, I mean we build this like
self-updating representation that tries
to keep track of where everything is. Um
not just the state of all the robots or
trucks or whatever moving around, but
also like the individual objects around
the facility. And um one of the big
challenges there is u is that you only
have partial observability. So it
doesn't matter how many cameras and and
robots you deploy on the site, there's
always going to be changes that you
didn't actually observe the change. And
so from from a challenge perspective,
then it becomes you basically two things
that you uh you need to worry about is
like you need to be able to reidentify
something. So, if it's not in the
location where you thought it's supposed
to be and you pass by and it's not
there, then if you see it somewhere
else, you need to be able to to match
and say it was the same thing. And in
some cases, it's a simple problem if
there's text or or a QR code or a
barcode on the thing. But if there's
not, then you have a pretty challenging
general object matching problem. Um, but
then there's the other thing is that if
it's not where if you didn't observe it,
were you supposed to see it?
>> Uh, were you occluded? Was there like a
like a pallet on on the truck that drove
by and that's why you didn't see it? And
so there uh there's actually no good
solution for that today except uh for a
bunch of huristics which I I think is a
there's a interesting challenge here to
be solved maybe by by some a gentic
system uh or maybe with something that's
more fundamental than than figuring out
sort of the logic manually.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. Interesting. And let me ask
you also a slightly different question.
I mean we've heard from some of the uh
keynote speeches also that you know from
uh the deployments where we have a
couple of robots in a particular
environment. Now we're looking at fleets
of robots operating. So presumably again
you're going to deal with this
environments with many many robots of
different types moving around. How do
you address that that challenge?
>> Um it's a good question right? It's uh
and it's again back to this the question
you asked about edge versus cloud. There
there are certain things you absolutely
need to run on edge like if if you're
moving robots around or vehicles around
in an industrial environment like real
time localization, real time safety
features like not colliding into things
and like all all of those things need to
run on edge, right? You can't move it
somewhere else because of latency. But
then all of the important things where
where you add value by aggregating all
the observations into a consistent
representation needs to happen on the
cloud side because every single observer
doesn't have the context it need to to
do the compute right so all of those
things you need to run on on cloud and
uh it could be agents reasoning over the
days activities it could be like
performance metrics it could be um
updating the location of where things
are you can't do that on edge that needs
to happen
in an aggregated sort of environment
where all the data is centralized.
>> Okay. So, kind of from where you sit
looking at at your use cases and your
industries. What I'm curious, we talked
a little bit about data, we talked a
little bit about, you know, some of the
hardware needs that that are emerging.
We talked a little bit about the models
and how they integrate all of this uh
data and interacts with the hardware.
Where do you think we need to make the
most I guess uh progress to see this
whole AI based robotics basically uh get
to the scale and get to the proper
commercial deployments? Where do you
think the biggest bottlenecks are and
where do we need to make the biggest
push? Data, hardware, AI models,
something else.
>> Well, yeah. So, I can uh I can uh jump
in about hardware. I think uh there's
there is a gap currently when it comes
to industrial-grade high resolution
cameras. It's like in general there's a
pretty good uh positive shift in the
industry with more and more cameras
being deployed from a traditionally like
LAR based robotics ecosystem. So, more
cameras. Good. I love it. But there's
still no industrial-grade camera that
will give you images of the what you
would get with your smartphone that what
you're holding in your hand. Basically,
there's nothing even close to that
available on the market. And uh I think
it's it's the demand is there and I'm
I'm hoping that the manufacturer will
catch up eventually.
>> Okay, good one. Y
>> maybe if I can quickly add to that.
Yeah. So, I I fully agree. It's it's
hardware, but it's also sort of how do
we actually deploy the hardware and
solve those let's say also connectivity
issues which allow you to recover
systems somewhat remotely fundamentally
and I'm not even my co-founder but it is
fundamentally a money game. So the
moment you send people out there to fix
stuff to always replace stuff, this is
never going to work out from a lucrative
business perspective as long as even if
your hardware costs drop substantially
and so on, right? So I think like sort
of fixing this like the way we deploy,
how we build things slowly, tackling
tasks that are simple and robust first
before like shooting a thousand VAS at
something and I'm a bit the sort of the
bad cop on AI here, although I of course
fully embrace it. um is is super
important and I I really think like we
underestimate this. It's actually what
we really quickly did did a bubble or
trying to bubble like we're throwing
things out there before they're ready to
understand how robust it is. I mean we
started without a solution to the
problem sort of and you know now we're
there but yeah think about things the
way things are deployed from a hardware
perspective is for me the biggest bo.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, I would uh I mean we build we
build hardware uh tactile hardware. It's
arguably the hardware that's in most
contact with the environment. [gasps] So
I would say like what was limiting the
entire field was durability of the
hardware. Uh this year actually a few
months ago we we launched about a month
ago we launched our first like scalable
tactile fingertip which can go to like
scale of thousands tens of thousands in
volume. But we didn't optimize for the
most cutting edge resolution for that
sensor. We optimized for the thing that
had not been sold in industry which was
high durability and you know in
industrial settings. So like a million
contact cycles you know hit it with a
hammer kind of thing. Um and still
maintain you know some ability to sense
and touch uh the the world around it. So
I think I think from again coming from
like a bit of a humanoids standpoint I
would say there is still a hardware
bottleneck but very soon afterwards
there's a software one which is how do
we understand all of this new data like
how do we incorporate it into reasoning
and all of all of that side of things.
Um, so yeah, I think it's a bit of both,
but right now I would definitely say
hardware. And again, from again very
niche perspective of like dextrous
hands. Last year the the the bottleneck
was actuators. This year it's tactile
sensors. And I think that's almost the
last hardware bottleneck. Once we've
overcome that at scale, then uh then we
can start worrying about how to how to
control. That will be the only problem.
And the intelligence sort of
interpreting and driving that.
>> Great. Thank you. Um I think that that
moment of asking your question is upon
us. So if you have a burning one, please
raise your hand.
I'm happy to keep asking mine, but this
is your chance.
>> Adam
Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. Um so where to
begin on the challenges of of ashore
robotics? Um so there's always like the
surface challenge, right? So especially
from a harder perspective for us like
we're saying we want to live at sea.
Basically it means we need to be
completely self-riting. we need to never
capsize. Uh we need to be able to like
restart if we have a system failure and
so on. So I think that's one of the
challenges. If we look subc the
challenges vary a lot with um depth. So
for instance if you're tackling kind of
shallow waters which we are initially
and by shallow waters I mean you know in
the 50 to 100 mters close to assets
you're dealing to with high currents
right and sort of these currents
increase close to your assets. So then
you need more bulky systems. More bulky
systems means more expensive systems
means higher energy usage means like we
want to do robots to live at sea. Oh no,
higher energy usage is we're screwed.
Well, we're trying not to be screwed and
we hope we hope to be to be addressing
that with bubble. But so that's for
instance in the shallow water areas,
right? At the same time there the
turbidity is extremely high. So
basically to answer your question, we
can use camera data you know 20 30% of
the time but we always have to augment
that with sonar data which is a
different type of data structure which
we then have to interpret in line with
what you were saying uh newly in sort of
the upcoming models right and then
there's the deep sea which we're not
tackling just yet and there it's very
much more of a pressure and light
problem right because most things that
go deep sea now are are going to be
tethered so it's about you need big
bulky systems you have one atmosphere of
pressure increase with every 10 meters.
If there's divers out there, you would
know you basically want to scream louder
and louder exponentially. Um, so yeah,
so I think you have to kind of separate
those two worlds. And actually, a lot of
the systems we have today, just to
finish off, are designed for that deep
sea world, but a lot of the assets that
we have today emerging are in the more
shallow water cases. So they don't scale
costwise at all. Um, so yeah, just to
quickly answer your question,
>> thank you.
a great question. If you didn't hear in
the back, it was about uh human and
robot coordination to be efficient.
paraphrasing a little bit. Um, how did
we solve it? Well, we didn't solve it
yet, but we're working on it. Um, um,
but no, I mean, it's it's like the
foundation for for um an efficient
automation of a of an industrial
facility is knowing where everything is
and having that knowledge shared with
all of the workers in the area. If they
are humans driving forklifts, if they're
robots manipulating things or moving
things, they need to share and have that
same understanding. And and even today,
like in a lot of facilities, they don't
like you don't even know the location of
your humans doing the work. So you don't
like if you're assigning a job, you
don't even know who to give it to. Uh
you might give it to the person that's
furthest away from the actual task. And
so there's sort of like basic things
like that. If you keep track of where
all the workers are, where all the
robots are, where all the things that
they need to work on are, and you share
that information, that's like step one.
How we solved it to make it like perfect
and efficient, like ask me again in 12
months.
>> Thank you.
And yeah, I'll just jump in here. Uh, by
the way, we made tactile sensors for
tidal turbine blades in the beginning uh
to sense water flow. Um, but yeah, but
that has challenges. So, uh, like like
air bubbles. Anyway, laminating them
onto the the title. Um, I mean, I just
want to say like I think VALAs are
interesting, but um, I haven't really
spoken at all about applications of um,
tactile that will have the most impact.
I think human robot interaction will be
have the most impact. I think it's the
biggest unrealized market. Putting
robots in hospitals. We're really
interested in doing things like
catheterizing patients where you have to
feel what the tube is doing inside the
body, but you have to feel it on your
fingertips outside the body at the
moment. Um, like I think VA's have a
long way to go. If you really look at
these kind of tasks, they're all being
teleoperated today. Like you still have
a human in the loop and yes, we have
haptic gloves. The human can feel what
the robot feels, but VALA's are not able
to do that. So, I think there's still
quite a long way to go where we have
like robots going into these
unstructured environments. We're getting
close, but they need to be able to uh to
handle more of this this kind of data
and really understand what's going on.
That's my two cents.
>> Last last question.
Sorry. Can I
So the question is yeah is there work on
force estimation and
>> so we're working on uh several other uh
tactile features. So weight estimation
would be one of them uh really precise
like we cal we calibrate our sensors so
you can get precise forces as well as
shear forces as well if you want that
kind of sensor variant. So sideways
shear forces, normal forces. Um
calibration is a big challenge we've
been trying to crack for for many years
at scale. So we can discuss that
separately. Um but yeah, tactile
features would include things not only
slip but hardness of the objects, uh
vibrations,
textures,
you know, whatever we classify as pain
and reacting to that, which is not up
here again. It's uh somewhere else the
compute for for going on for that. So
edge compute you could probably call it.
So yeah, this would kind of all form a
middle layer. We're actually trying to
make the first open-source model in the
world that works across all tactile
sensor transduction modalities and can
generalize across them and we're going
to be releasing that with Arya at some
point. So not just PZO resistive skins
that we build, but also capacitive
sensors, magnetic based tactile sensors
and of course vision based sensors which
are the easiest to work with. Um so
absolutely all the tactile features over
time need to be understood and then the
question is how do you translate that to
the VA right now we're playing with
translating it into language as well but
language is slow but VALA's are also
slow so if we react at a lower level and
extract some features can we just plug
into VAS anyway I'll leave it at there
we're doing a lot of stuff and
experimenting with a lot of things there
>> okay thank you very much thank you for
your questions and thank you very much
Zaki Patricia and Yaneric. Uh, everyone,
>> thanks.